as I mentioned you know Vietnam warm
against it got it uh you think that you
know you think that America doesn't
belong in Iraq anymore I understand it I
don't it doesn't matter if I agree I
understand it but you need a degree of
thought and research to understand why
you believe that Palestine should be
there that uh that uh Israel should not
be defending itself what the history was
in 1948 what about the 20s with the Bal
for declaration you got to actually
think you pick up your phone ask Google
or your AI app you know what exactly it
is I don't think any of them have any
idea it's just whatever's counter to
what America is doing to the point where
even the Democratic Administration can't
control the Democratic Administration
who they
hire I'm Dave ruin and joining me today
is the co-anchor of fox and friends the
host of the Brian kill radio show and
author of the newly released book Teddy
and Booker T Brian kilme welcome back to
the Reuben report Dave it's great to see
you it's good to see you because you
have 87 gigs and 45 other jobs and a
whole bunch of other stuff we have
limited time here so I thought for a
couple minutes we'll kind of talk about
news of the day and the media then we'll
dive into the book uh you know in this
news cycle that we've been in for the
last two months have you ever felt that
the world at least from the position
that you are taken every day on that
couch is is kind of crazier and more out
of control or is this just another
recycled version of the craziness with a
new topic well I think solvable I I I I
don't think anything is so complex where
you think where where's the way out of
this the mud I think everything is
solvable I mean for example in the
Middle East so how do you solve it we
can't totally solve it I can tell you
who the problem is and you know it it's
Iran right uh asking them not to to be
nice and to be in the family of Nations
I think it's safe to say the experiment
fail
all right Hamas houie Rebels thanks for
keeping it all hes hezb the problem
Believe It or Not these other nations
are actually seeing eye to eye with us
in many ways and we did a good job if I
told you 15 years ago Al-Qaeda and Isis
would be marginalized we'd be all over
them uh and you know we could kind of
move on with ourselves and the Saudis
for the most part would straighten out
their school system and we wouldn't be
raising generations of terrorists you
would say Brian you're dreaming but
really there's one nation that's the
problem and they saw the Middle East
coming into line with the rest of the
world and they decided to try to blow it
up with our our key Ally the biggest
surprise Dave has to be the protests has
to be the college campuses you know if
you're against the Vietnam War I can
make sense if you're if you think
African-Americans are getting a hard
having a hard time with law enforcement
let's hear your case I get it but I
don't get this I do not get the oh the
Palestinian cause or Palestine needs to
be free and let me explain to you how
much MOS means to me I'm thinking to
myself maybe for a day but I mean this
is getting bigger and bigger and over
the weekend the Manhattan Bridge being
shut down by these Knuckleheads asking
for a SE ceasefire in the middle of a
ceasefire kind of
unique does it surprise you that much
though I mean you guys cover all the
college craziness every morning on your
show as much as I do I mean with with
that as the backdrop to me it was not
that surprising actually too complex you
know like I as I mentioned you know
Vietnam warm against it got it uh you
think that you know you think that
America doesn't belong in Iraq anymore I
understand it I don't it doesn't matter
if I agree understand it but you need a
degree of thought and research to
understand why you believe that
Palestine should be there that uh that
uh Israel should not be defending itself
what the history was in 1948 what about
the 20s with the Bal for declaration you
got to actually think you got to pick up
your phone ask Google or your AI app you
know what exactly it is I don't think
any of them have any idea it's just
whatever's counter to what America is
doing to the point where even the
Democratic Administration can't control
the Democratic Administration who
they how do you uh how do you go about
covering the news every morning in that
you're doing a Morning Show you're
trying to be light about stuff and you
guys do a nice blend of kind of fun
light stuff but then also the serious
stuff it's it's kind of uh it's bipolar
in some ways I suppose I think it's like
you you have a great sense of humor but
when you speak you you do it from a well
researched background this is my opinion
this is what I have to say but you'll be
self-deprecating you'll make fun of
other people not me because I think you
you're a little afraid of me I leave
that to Gutfeld I leave that to Gutfeld
yeah thank you but I I think it's the
same balance you know uh we try to you
try to pick your spots the day of the
War uh de October 7th if you're kidding
around you're in the wrong business
business you pick your spots during the
day and you see some of the craziness
2024 to me is very much like sports you
you break it down you look at the
strategies you look at the candidates
you look at the performance you look at
the numbers the polls uh I I mean I love
that stuff so you can have fun on the
other side but when it comes to you know
routing you know going into Hamas
tunnels and you're tossing to Trey Yanks
not the time to go for a laugh yeah for
the record he has become one of the best
Jal ists in the business like top five
the guy has just been absolutely
absolutely incredible let me just ask
you one other political thing and then
and then I want to talk about the book
cuz you just mentioned 24 and you know
fox is in an interesting spot because
there is this Trump to santis thing my
sense is the polls don't make much sense
actually and I think on the ground is a
little bit different than that but how
aware are you of uh what your what the
base of your audience wants versus what
you're thinking versus what your
co-hosts are thinking and the general
Zeitgeist is when when you're covering
all this stuff well I mean I'm lucky
enough I go on the five a lot and you
know fill in at night so and then I got
the Saturday show which is really and
you've been on yeah is really I feel
like it's my own thing one thing about
us we don't deconflict with the hosts so
like we don't see each other until two
minutes before and I don't think anyone
benefits from trying to get on the same
page with your host uh seriously uh but
um I'm not really worried about the base
especially for the fact that many people
like sobody in the Trump World are mad
at Fox and they like Fox and then they
don't it's impossible you know if you
say something nice about Nikki Haley or
Ronda santz that's called you know
following the storyline but another
since they're running against Trump a
lot of times the Trump people get
offended uh but you can't keep up with
it if you tried your head would explode
yeah and also Trump uh Trump sometimes
hates Fox and other times you know we I
go back and forth with him uh on on the
air off air and I I don't think he Minds
The sparring and I think it's going to
be fascinating I mean for anyone who's a
republican to say Ronda santis is the
enemy I find that laughable if anyone
doesn't see the talent of uh Nikki Haley
on the right I think that's kind of you
know you might not be your might not be
your the person you're voting for but my
goodness that resume that strength that
background husbands in the military
stationed over in Africa kids uh Indian
sent you know uh NOS International ran a
really good state if you disagree with
their own policy but to get mad at me
because I have an interview with her or
that type of stuff I can't I can't let
that get you know they can't get to you
and also you know nobody in the Trump
World Loves Chris Christie but please
tell me an issue that Chris Christie is
not conversing on and it's you know the
guy's extremely bright and successful
he's he made his his thing has got
running against Trump sometimes you have
Chris Christie especially on the radio
show and Affiliates will like go ask me
you know what am I doing I'm like what
am I doing I'm rounding out the
conversation yeah what doing look of
course if you're on you know roughly our
side of this thing that bench is a hell
of a lot deeper than what's going on on
the other side and that's the part that
we should probably all kind of come
together on but let let's shift to the
book for a couple minutes because I saw
the title of the book and I haven't read
it yet I've got a copy here but uh this
was not a book that I would have
expected you to write I I just didn't
know this was interesting to you or that
you that this is sort of in your
wheelhouse couple of things they did the
president Freedom Fighter Frederick
Douglas and Abraham Lincoln that battle
for America soul and I want to move up
in time I kind of I always passion for
history the reason why uh Dave we
probably would get along uh if we hung
out it's because we have passion for
news and I want to put it in perspective
history helps me and I enjoy it number
two is I so I did George Washington
secret 6 book about the Spy ring I
looked at that for 20 years and bill riy
was actually one that said I never heard
of this story you should do it kind of
helped me through it and then I started
doing one after another and I got to
Civil War and I was like Duck it it's
George Floyd stay away from it you don't
want you don't want to talk about race
like what if I did it through two great
Americans who would eventually come
together but I also read Up From Slavery
and here's why you would like the book
it just talks about two Americans in
rough circumstances physically with
Teddy rosfeld almost died asthma and all
that um lost his his wife and his mom
and the same day even though he had
money it doesn't mean he had an easy
life and then you have another guy born
to slavery until he was 9 years old and
I read Up From Slavery and I put the
book down I could not stop thinking
about it and I just thought who could I
pair this with because there's been so
many biographies and he wrote his own
and updated three or four times like
Frederick Douglas and then I see Teddy
Roosevelt all over it I went to the
Roosevelt people and I say Am I Dreaming
to talk about this friendship or is this
just a couple years they no no this this
is real not often written about they
helped me did a fox Nation special on it
and if people want to say in 2023 I got
to take a knee at a football game
because we're not racially sensitive
enough if you want to kneel down at a US
national soccer team game because you
don't feel as though uh life is fair for
all Races Creed and colors get a
perspective he was born in the
segregated South as a slave loved the
country and all he did is try to educate
Generations
at Tuskegee and then spread that
throughout the country without any
bitterness without any hate could have
went anywhere and been a celebrity
instead he starts teaming with great
Americans like Andrew Carnegie JP Morgan
Teddy Roosevelt William mckenley Grover
Cleveland and made us better and that's
my hope you'll read this and love the
country a little more while still being
very unhappy with segregated South you
know I'm not sure if you're aware of
this I'm I'm watching a show on HBO
called the Gilded Age right now and
Booker T Washington is in it at least
for a couple episodes that that I'm in
at the moment and Tuskegee and all of
that and one of the things that I keep
thinking as I'm watching it is boy you
know for as terrible as obviously
slavery was and all of the inequality
and everything else the way it's framed
in the show is there were a lot of
people trying to get past it and we're
talking now you know 150 years ago
roughly and and I think we really do
forget that more than anything else
that's what you're referencing with the
people that are kneeling and everything
else that these guys they were trying it
when it was much harder to do and they
were succeeding in a lot of ways so
there's this you know the famous White
House dinner when he invites Booker T
Washington for dinner because he's a
great man not that he's black or white
and the whole C portions of the country
erupt into a scandal how dare F Teddy
Roosevelt diminish the white race by
bringing in a black man to have with
them even if he's the most famous black
man in America and the most respected
perhaps on all walks not everywhere it's
outrageous the headlines will just make
almost pass out with anger and and
distraught however he overcame it all
they just brought their relationship
under the wire he became a key resource
with naming judges and everything else
told him about what African-Americans
need he became a keynote speaker at
Tuskegee one one on tusk's board and
this is a man who was brought up by a
Confederate mom who whose two brothers
fought for the South so think about Tay
Roosevelt overcoming the times still
said some things that will make you say
wow he's clearly got some flying spots
but these guys just saw opportunity to
make the country better and and while
while loving it and also knew that they
couldn't rush it there's certain things
in America they weren't ready and I'll
give you one great story I know you got
a million interviews but so Teddy
Roosevelt and Booker T Washington have
dinner and it caused a great uproar but
they knew they did nothing wrong and he
was going to be an advisor anyway so
Booker T Washington's Waiting for a
Train in the South to go north and Hawai
walks up to him and says you Booker T
Washington he says yeah CU you're a
great American you might be our greatest
American he said no thank you but the
greatest American is our president Ted
Roosevelt he said I used to think so
till he invited you over for
dinner now think about that so many
different levels and this guy did not
know he insulted me and he does in that
type of level of on my word ignorance so
I'm not mad at him I just took it in I
told he told President Roosevelt about
the story they both laughed and he said
I have to let sleeping dogs lie not
going to fight every battle and that's
what got web de booys angry why are you
so accepting of Injustice he's like no
this is the world I'm in I'm making it
better while in the South yeah and not
I'm not saying everyone in the south in
his era in the turn of the century 20th
century was racist segregation they
weren't but there was a lot of people
who grew up tell being told that whites
and blacks were different and there was
different uh capabilities for both he
said I don't hate them I'm just going to
change Chang their minds by our actions
the other thing Dave that they do
everyone who who went to tus gige
learned to trade he said you have to be
indispensable if there not people aren't
ready to hire you they have to hire you
because you're too
valuable couldn't we all learn a little
Su of that right now instead of
affirmative action maybe actually having
skills and proving it and all that stuff
Brian I I really wish we had more time I
absolutely going to read the book and I
think I'm on Fox and Friends on Friday
morning so we'll pick it up then all
right I'll have some look forward to
let's make sure we don't the same
outfit but we will make fun of Greg
Gutfeld how about that if let's agree
let's agree to that Dave congratulations
on everything and I'm on locals too now
oh you are all right we're gonna link
down to your locals and of course we'll
link down to the book all right thanks a
lot go get them Dave awesome man thanks
if you're looking for more uncensored
opinions from today's thought leaders
check out our media playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell